de la musique à la poésie pour les
yvelines à présent oui de la poésie
contemporaine puisque donc ce soir lydia
padellec vous venez nous parler du prix
que vous avez reçu ce matin donc le prix
poésie vinh des collégiens 2013 donc
pour votre recueil la maison morcelé
alors déjà j'ai envie de vous demander
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce prix
représente pour vous
c'est un prix hautement symboliques
alors déjà parce que il est décerné par
le département alors moi je suis des
yvelines depuis
j'ai fait toute ma scolarité dans les
yvelines donc c'est vrai que pour moi
c'est ses traits ses traits
c'est très symbolique
et puis le fait aussi que ce soit des
collégiens qui le décerne jeu ça me
touche beaucoup alors des collégiens
c'est un public que vous connaissez pas
ce que vous menez des voilages heures
d'écriture avec avec ces jeunes voilà je
mène des ateliers d'écriture en fait
depuis 2004 donc c'est vrai que c'est ça
un public que je connais bien
et c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment superbe que qu'ils aient
adoré mon livre est justement alors
qu'elles ont été le retour ce matin vous
les avez rencontrées lors de cette
remise de prix qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dit c'est un requin qui les a
touchés
ils ont beaucoup aimé justement cette
maison
qu'on visite pièce par pièce et il y en
a même un élève qui m'a dit
quand on lisait ses textes j'avais
l'impression d'être dans la maison de
mes arrière grands parents voilà deux
mais ça fait appel à des souvenirs là ça
fait appel à des souvenirs alors cette
maison c'est une maison d'enfance et
voilà ça mais les autres grands mères
alors racontez nous justement donc
comment vous avez construit votre
ouvrage alors au début c'est vrai que
quand ma grand mère est décédée
l'écriture de c'est la poésie est venue
assez rapidement mais je n'avais pas
trouvé la forme donc j'ai écrit de
différentes façons alors au début c'est
vrai que j'ai fait appel à des mots en
breton
ensuite c'est une maison en bretagne
voilà bien sûr
et
donc après c'est vrai que j'ai écrit
sous forme de 4 1 et à partir de ces 4 1
j'ai commencé à parler de l'intérieur
d'une maison mais la forme du quatrain
ne me convenait pas et c'est en mai 2009
que j'ai commencé en fait à écrire des
poèmes en prose peut-être vous pouvez
nous lire alors je peux effectivement
vaut lire le premier poème qui avait
vraiment déclenché qui a tout déclenché
le soir la maison paraît plus vaste de
son silence plus vide aussi
les ombres joue à cache cache dans ses
recoins des rires lointain se font
entendre un écho dans la lumière la
petite fille est morte en même temps que
la maison
découverte au bas de l'escalier les
plumes déchirer
alors la maison morcelé est-ce que c'est
elle
votre type le premier choix de ce titre
de recueil alors non au début c'est
s'appelait la maison aux racines bleus
en racines ses allées l'origine en fait
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
la racine bleus voilà c'était un mélange
de l'arbre et de l'océan et je me suis
dit non c'est pas un très bon titre et
la maison morcelé ça m'est venu parce
que
sai la maison dorcel en fait c'est une
métaphore de la mémoire c'est le
souvenir fragmenter la mémoire qui se
commet dire qu'ils se morcelle donc à ce
que vous faites en est fait allusion
aussi à votre grand-mère qui était
atteinte d'alzheimer donc à beaucoup
dont c'est tout dans ce recueil dans ses
poèmes de métaphore comme vous le disiez
d'image qui associe les mots et
incertain souvenir donc pour vous et
alors ce qui est un étonnant c'est enfin
l'ambiance l'ambiance en tout cas est
est très importante on tient vraiment
une place importante et c'est une
atmosphère assez particulière
cette maison elle et elle est vide mais
en même temps elle est envahie par les
insectes alors pourquoi voilà ça c'est
ça aussi c'est étonnant 2 pourquoi
parlez-vous d'insectes en fait pour moi
les insectes ça représente un peu la
maladie l'image par exemple des mythes
qui grignotent les vêtements pour moi
c'est vraiment la métaphore de la
maladie vous parlez d'abeilles aussi
alors les abeilles c'est vraiment or
c'est un petit peu autre chose pour moi
les abeilles c'est un insecte qui est
fragile comme l'enfance et si on fait
pas attention effectivement la bei peut
disparaître et aussi à un moment donné
un passage
vous évoquez une araignée alors oui
ça c'est vraiment un souvenir que j'ai
vraiment à l'avocat d'emile s'entendre
et dv et voilà l'assaisonnement à
souvenirs que j'ai ressenti dans ma
chair parce que j'étais dans dans cette
maison j'étais tout petit et une nuit
j'ai fait un cauchemar je rêvais
justement de cette araignée qui était
sur ma cuisse et c'était très angoissant
et j'ai appelé ma grand-mère au secours
dormez trop profondément mais voilà en
fait ça c'est vraiment un souvenir
vraiment vécu qui m'a marqué cet ouvrage
que vous avez crié fonctionne comme quoi
mc caw thérapie c'est un petit peu le
but aussi j'aime pas trop j'aime pas
trop se perdre
c'est l'idée oui c'est vrai que ça ça me
permet aussi de faire un petit peu le
deuil mais c'est aussi faire un hommage
à ma grand mère
choisit effectivement alors nous avons
rencontré jacques fournier qui vous a
remis donc ce matin même de ses mains le
prix de poésie flynn 2013 on va
l'écouter donc il était au micro de
julien rochas soares nous parler d'eux
pour lui ce que reprennent ce qu'a
représenté à votre travail
je suis lydia depuis très longtemps
puisque l ael gela programme dans le
festival poésie yvelines elle a lu à la
maison de la poésie
encore en mode de mars avec d'autres
poètes et
je sais que j'ai aimé la profondeur mais
je suis breton aussi donc ça a dû jouer
beaucoup la maison au bord de la mer je
connais ou presque la maison de la
grand-mère je connais donc il ya
beaucoup d'affect là dedans mais il
n'empêche que c'est une véritable
écriture qui est en train d'émerger là
surtout sur cette forme de prose courte
ce qu'elle a utilisés - peut-être dans
la position qui termine le livre mais
voilà et se mélange à la fois de deux
réalités de souvenirs de fantasmes
presque sur une maison ou dans laquelle
on retourne où on est on n'a plus la
même taille et n'est plus une enfant de
10 ans elle est une adulte et on voit
pas les choses de la même manière et
puis il ya le temps qui passe qui
s'installe et n'empêche qu'en dessous la
poussière du temps reste le souvenir et
le souvenir vivace de la grand mère et
je trouve ça se trouve c'est un beau
livre c'est une reconnaissance dans un
micro cause mais c'est très important
quand même voilà je pense que son
travail trouvera sa place petit à petit
là et vient de publier aux éditions de
l'amandier un recueil de haïkus c'est
parce que je préfère chez elle mais
cette reconnaissance quand une bonne
maison d'édition avec laquelle on
travaille aussi régulièrement et la
preuve d'une qualité d'écriture
alors j'ai la sanction est difficile à
leurs fins comme un petit peu même
rebondir quand jacques fourni parle de
haïkus donc vous c'est un style
d'écriture que vous avez réfectionner
voilà vous avez de l'intérêt pour
peut-être rappeler déjà ce que c'est que
le haïku alors le haïku ça un petit
poème d'origine japonaise donc qui
évoque un instant de vie alors c'est
vrai que moi j'ai découvert le haïku en
2001 à travers un poète qui s'appelle
issa ça a été vraiment une révélation
pour moi si vous voulez je peux vous le
dire les montagnes lointaines se reflète
dans les prunelles de la libellule
voilà c'est l'immensité dans le procès
qui devait commencer et c'est vraiment
voilà c'est très peu nous donc vous vous
affectionnez ce style d'écriture voilà
d'ailleurs vous l'avez utilisé dans la
maison morcelé en l'esprit saint et
l'état serait oui
et donc vous vous reconnaissez vraiment
voilà dans
dans ce style littéraire et donc alors
vos projets futurs quels sont ils alors
alors mes projets futurs
donc je continue d'écrire des haïkus
même si c'est vrai que là je suis plus
dans la poésie en vers libres donc
j'écris en rapport avec les arts j'aime
beaucoup associé les arts avec la poésie
en particulier la peinture je
m'intéresse beaucoup vous êtes
plasticienne oui oui oui
et donc en particulier avec le peintre
matisse je m'intéresse beaucoup à son
travail et sinon j'ai effectivement un
livre qui va paraître au mois d'octobre
aux éditions henry donc la collection la
manne des poètes
donc par contre là c'est autre chose ça
ça ça n'a rien à voir avec le haïku ni
la peinture c'est plus en rapport avec
la l'amour et la musique lui ça reste
dans le domaine de la poésie et ça reste
dans le domaine de la poésie bien sûr
vous pouvez bien découvrir bien
évidemment découvrir ce recueil de
poèmes la maison ensorcelé édition est
pénalisé l'ars la maison blanche